- Première expédition de l'année
de homard vivant de l'aéroport
de Moncton.
- Destination finale : la Chine,
à Ningbo. Ningbo, ça se trouve
environ à trois heures de route
à l'ouest de Shanghai.
- Dans cet immense entrepôt
frigorifique, on prépare
la cargaison : 100 tonnes
de homards, de quoi remplir
à pleine capacité un avion
747 cargo. Les crustacés y sont
soigneusement entreposés sur
39 palettes. Tout doit se faire
rapidement pour s'assurer que
le homard arrive vivant de
l'autre côté du Pacifique.
PAUL FARRAH, pdg,
Xtreme Cold Ice
- On va dire, entre 40 et
60 heures, là, on va avoir 5 %
de taux de mortalité au maximum,
OK. Au-delà de 60 heures hors de
l'eau, là le taux de mortalité
commence à s'accélérer.
- Le crustacé provient en très
grande majorité des viviers
de la Nouvelle-Écosse et
du Nouveau-Brunswick,
comme ici, à Back Bay.
Nathan Song exporte 80 %
de sa cargaison de homard vivant
en Chine.
Il prévoit faire des affaires
d'or avec les fe
entourant le Nouvel An chinois,
qui aura lieu le 21 janvier.
Les exportations canadiennes
de homard vivant à destination
de la Chine ont considér
augmenté au cours des
cinq dernières années, passant
de près 260 millions de dollars
en 2018 à 420 millions
de dollars en 2022.
Leseseseseses exportations
date d'avant la pandémie.
Maintenant que la Chine
relâche peu à peu ses mesures
sanitaires, les producteurs
canadiens  q q q q q que
les affaires reprendront
de plus belle.
18 h 30 heure locale,
le 747 cargo de Kalitta Air
atterrit à l'Aéroport de
Moncton. Aussitôt, le homardviv:
L'avion repart dans à peine
trois heures.
"L'industrie du homard vivant
a un potentielanananananance
important pour la région", dit
la PDG de l'Aéroport de Moncton.
Nathan Song a agrandi
son vivier de Back Bay
durant les années de pandémie
pour se préparer à la reprise
économique en Chine.
Il s'attend à doubler ses envois
dans le futur. u u u u u u un 7,
on n'aura plus d'espace.
- Paul Farrah prévoit ajouter,
de son côté, une extension à
ses entrepôts pour, notamment,
pouvoir approvisionn
temps deux avions cargos
de homard vivant.
Il espère que le marché et
la politique lui souriront,
parce qu'exporter du homard,
c'est aussi de la diplomatie
et les relations entre
le Canada et la Chine
sont pour le moins tendues.ueuee
par nos politiciens ont un poids
significatif sur les résultats
qu'on risque d'avoir en fin
d'année.
- De marché émergent, la Chine
est désormais devenu un
incontournable pour
canadien, mais demeure instable
et imprévisible.
Raison pour laquelle des
exportateurs, comme Paul Farrah,
songent à diversifier
leurs marchés en Asie dans les
prochaines années, avec des pays
comme l'Inde, le Vietnam, la
Thaïlande et la Corée du Sud.
Ici Nicolas Steinbach,
Radio-Canad